foreign
another question here this one's from
YouTube Vera has something for us I
don't enjoy gifts at all I don't like
getting them and I definitely don't like
trying to figure out what to get for
other people I find it overwhelming and
a waste of time to me how do I avoid
obligations around gift giving
well Vera a gift turns into a curse
when it becomes an obligation
if you feel like you have to give a gift
to someone or you have to receive a gift
and of course the metaphor that I like
to use TK if I handed you a brick of dog
crap
[Laughter]
I got this gift for you
it's going to be really easy for you to
reject that now of course that's a
parotic exaggeration of gift giving but
quite often when gift giving is
obligatory what happens is I give you
some crap that you didn't want that's
right and by me giving you a bunch of
crap that you don't want and now you
even have to pretend to be grateful for
it you have to put on a smile oh thanks
Josh I really was hoping to get a piece
of crap
I love your laugh I just I just have a
visual of a brick that's just too much
species
there's a big dog
and and so where we are right now is
we're in a culture that expects us to be
grateful for the crap people give us oh
man and it expects us to also expect
crap from other people if you didn't get
me something just get me something I
don't care what it is then you don't
care about me well do you really care
about me if you just got me some crap
yeah
yeah that's so true man
another aspect of this gift-giving
obligation is that
you have to muster up the courage to
disappoint people early
now you must disappoint people that's a
part of life there's no escaping that we
are all continually disappointing
someone somewhere
but when you can disappoint people
earlier you you allow them to have time
to not only get over it but you you
create the space where they can process
things in a way that leads to a
healthier response and to increased
respect for you so let me give an
example this often comes up in the uh
professional space where someone says uh
they agree to a deadline I'm going to
get this report done by the 31st of this
month and they've got some insecurities
about their ability to do it there are
some things coming up as the month is
going on and they're nervous they're
scared because they don't want to
disappoint it's the 14th of the month
and they're thinking I might not be able
to hit this deadline but they don't want
to disappoint so they say well let me
see where I'm at a week from now and
then it's like the 22nd and they're like
I'm totally not going to hit this
deadline it's going to take me three
extra days but they don't want to
disappoint and so they wait and then
it's the 31st and then the person they
made the promise to says how are we
looking on that project and they're like
well this happened and that happened and
this happened and that happened
and that person's usually a little livid
a lot of trust is broken right why
because the expectation that it was
going to be delivered was on this day
and we're here at this day and this is
the first time I'm finding out that
there's a problem and I made all of
these other plans contingent on you
delivering on our agreement I've had
conversations with this person I've
blocked out this time I've committed
resources to this
but if that person had simply
disappointed early and said hey on the
12th I won't be able to deliver on the
31st I'm going to need a few a few days
that other person might have still been
disappointed but because they would have
had time to adjust the disappointment
would be much easier for them to process
if the family is expecting you to come
over on Christmas that message ain't
gonna go very well if you call them up
on Christmas morning or Christmas Eve
but if you call them up in the middle of
March and say FYI this this and that we
won't be able to make it for Christmas
oh yeah they'll still be mad they'll
still be disappointed but they've got
time to process and that gives you a
much better chance and so when it comes
to gifts I think
build a reputation for being the kind of
person that you want to be and when you
get an invite to something be like hey I
don't do the whole gift giving thing but
tell people what you're going to do
instead yeah I won't be doing the gift
giving thing but I'm totally happy to
support you all I'm definitely going to
be there with bells and whistles on I'm
super excited but I just want to be
transparent and give you a heads up
because I know this is a normal custom
that's usually part of the expectation
people can usually respect that when
you're upfront with them even if it
initially feels disappointing if you're
going to disappoint disappoint early up
front and in a matter that's direct and
you won't have to do it often because
people will know that's just you that's
just his Mo that's just how they are I
think you'll find you at a certain point
you won't even have to tell them that
right I don't do gifts you can simply
tell them what you are willing to do
right and instead of saying no no no get
your gifts away from me I don't want
that piece of crap right that's why I
use that as a metaphor here obviously
don't tell anyone do you think their
gifts are crap and I don't want to get
you crap either right instead of telling
them no tell them what you are willing
to do I find that to be much more
powerful we have two rules than our
minimalist rule book it's 16 rules for
living with less you can download it for
free at the minimalists.com
rulebook one of them is the minimalist
gift-giving Rule and one is the
minimalist gift getting rule you're like
a minimalist yeah I I still get gifts as
a minimalist but I've set up these rules
in my life for giving gifts so I'm not
telling people no no no I'm not going to
give you a gift but I have a rule around
that has to do with consumable items
being able to give you a something that
you will enjoy and I did it with
intention right and also asking for
better gifts is part of the minimalist
gift getting rule you can download that
for free there's 16 rules for living
with less in there you can read that in
like half an hour the whole book is uh
it's 16 chapters but they're really
really short they're like a paragraph or
two each and you to walk away with 16
rules that will help you live more with
less about minimalists.com
rulebook for that did you enjoy this
Standalone patreon highlight if so you
can listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free